[Musique]
bonjour je suis ATIS barré conseiller
municipal à la ville de poissie en
charge du bien-être animal alors
aujourd'hui nous sommes venus à la
rencontre d'une vétérinaire qui a bien
voulu nous recevoir pour nous répondre à
nos questions précieuses pour passer
l'hiver comment faire passer l'hiver à
son
[Musique]
chien
bonjour Docteur merci beaucoup de nous
avoir accueilli aujourd'hui à la
Clinique Vétérinaire de poissie alors il
fait froid et donc nous avons quelques
questions pour savoir comment faire
passer l'hiver à son chien je voulais
savoir est-ce que le pelage du chien est
suffisant pour faire passer le froid
faut-il lui tricoter un pull par exemple
alors le la sensibilité au froid chez
les chiens dépend beaucoup de leur
taille de leur
race de leur
âge notamment les chiens de petite race
qui vont avoir un poil très fin ou une
peau très fine comme par exemple les
chihuahua vont être beaucoup plus
sensibles au froid en revanche un grand
chien qui est actif va être beaucoup
moins sensible au froid donc
pratiquement finalement les mentons vont
être indiqué pour les les manteaux
pardon vont être indiqués pour les
chiens de petite race ou qui sont âgés
en général on commence à préconiser les
manteaux lorsque les températures
s'approchent de de zéro je voulais aussi
préciser que pour les races qui se
subissent des toilettages par exemple un
caniche un poil assez long et qu'il va
sortir du toilettage il va se retrouver
avec une une protection en moins de
manière assez brutale il y aura donc pas
d'adaptation et là il est indiqué quand
même de mettre un manteau pour pour
permettre de passer ce stade de la
repousse du poil et de l'adaptation du
chien alors par exemple là en ce moment
il pleut beaucoup le gel va arriver
également est-ce qu'il faut leur mettre
un Cahouet est-ce qu'il faut comment
protéger leur cousiner leur mettre des
bottes de la crème alors en ce qui
concerne le manteau
imperméable je dirais que ça dépend
essentiellement de la dépense physique
que va avoir le l'animal si c'est un
jeune chien qu'on emmène à forêt et puis
qui va qui va courir qu'il va se
promener il craindra absolument pas la
pluie si si la promenade a une durée
normale d'une demi-heure à 1 heure et au
retour et bien on le on le sèche on le
frictionne ou au besoin on le sèche au
séchoir vraiment il fait froid en
revanche un petit chien qui ne fait pas
beaucoup d'effort là il pourrait être
intéressant de lui mettre un un manteau
imperméable il y a vraiment un cas où
les bottines peuvent être indiqué
notamment la la une précaution vis-à-vis
des coussinés c'est lorsque c'est un
temps de neige ou de Vergl et où il y a
des potx sur la route de sel et en fait
c'est plus le sel qui va être toxique
pour les pâtes et les coussinets et où
là il faut faire attention et lorsqu'on
soupçonne que les rues ont été sal il
est très important de rincer les pattes
à l'eau clair lorsqu'on rentre de
promenade alors on a parlé de dépenses
physique donc en hiver je suppose que le
chien dépense plus de calories est-ce
qu'il faut lui donner encore plus de
nourriture pour passer l'hiver la
plupart des chiens ne vivent pas dehors
ils vivent dans un appartement ou une
maison qui est chauffée et donc il n'y a
pas de déperdition majeure de de
calories ce qui fait que pour les
sorties quotidiennes
habituelles ça ne va pas forcément
nécess citer une augmentation de la
ration calorique est-ce qu'il y a des
traitements particuliers à faire
également en hiver alors des traitements
particuliers non mais ce qui est
important de faire c'est de ne pas
interrompre les traitements
antiparasitaires notamment pour les
parasites externes les PUFs mais surtout
les tics puisque les Tices peuvent être
vectrices de maladies graves dans la
pyroplasmose et avec le réchauffement
climatique on a des hivers assez doux et
où les ques peuvent être présentes même
en décembre en janvier ou en février
donc il est recomander de ne pas
interrompre les les traitements
antiparasitaires externes très bien
merci beaucoup docteur merci donc nous
avons eu de précieux conseils pour faire
passer l'hiver à son chien comme
d'habitude on garde le bon sens de
l'activité physique une alimentation
équilibrée et puis la chose
indispensable dont a besoin votre chien
c'est votre amour pour Lui réchauffer
son cœur à très bientôt sur tv78 la
chaîne amis des animaux